[Music]
okay hello everybody I'm very excited to
be here to share with you all about the
NASA frontier development lab and its
partnership with Google cloud so my name
is Megan Ansel I'm a postdoctoral fellow
at UC Berkeley in the Astronomy
Department my background is in
astrophysics and planetary science and
today I'm going to tell you about FTL I
participated in FDL last year in 2018 so
the NASA frontier development lab is a
public-private partnership between NASA
and partners in industry that
specialized in space and artificial
intelligence and the goal of NASA FDL is
to create innovative solutions to
problems that are of interest not just
to NASA but to humanity in general so
FDL has focused on problems like
planetary defense so trying to find
asteroids that might be on a collision
course with earth before they hit us so
that we don't end up like the dinosaurs
also looking at problems like space
weather so trying to track flares on our
Sun so that we can better understand the
impacts to satellites in orbit that we
depend a lot on like our GPS satellites
and the way this works is that FTL puts
on an eight-week research accelerator
down at the SETI Institute in Silicon
Valley over the summer and the way it
works is that there are these
four-person teams the teams are made up
of two space science subject matter
experts and to machine learning
researchers and they work very intensely
together for these eight weeks on a
challenge that's been given to them so
this past year for FDL there were five
challenge areas it was space resources
space weather astrobiology Earth
Observation and exoplanets and each one
of these challenge areas was supported
by one of our private partners and these
are these private partners are really
leaders in commercial AI so Google cloud
of course but also companies like KX IBM
Nvidia and Intel and we also had support
from some of the leaders in private
space so companies like Lockheed Martin
and space resources so this is the 2018
NASA FDL cohort we're all smiling and
looking fresh-faced because this is the
beginning of the summer we looked very
much more tired at the end of it but for
good reasons so we were a very
interdisciplinary and diverse group this
is a very special group of people about
50% of us were based in the United
States as researchers the other 50% were
from around the world a lot of us were
PhDs so some of us had PhDs in
astrophysics others had PhDs and things
like computer vision robotics it was a
wide range there also people from
industry that came from companies like
Hyperloop and Apple outtie just to name
a few and it's really because of our
partnerships with companies like Google
cloud that we could all come together
for the summer and work on these really
exciting challenges through this very
unique program of NASA FDL so we also
had some pretty amazing data sets to
work with sometimes NASA gave us these
data sets
other times we had to generate the data
sets using the wonderful compute power
tools through through companies like
Google cloud this particular data set
was used by the space weather team this
last year this is a real image of our
Sun taken by NASA's Solar Dynamics
Observatory which is in Earth orbit
right now and it looks for activity on
the Sun so that we can better understand
the impact of that on earth so it
analyzed these data sets we had access
to a very diverse AI toolkit and just
vast amounts of compute power again
provided to us by our private partners
and I have to say so I'm a scientist in
academia and this was truly amazing we
do not have access to resources like
this normally and it was very
eye-opening to see what kind of science
could be done in an incredibly short
amount of time when you're given just
the best resources that are available so
today I'm going to talk to you about two
of the challenges from last year's NASA
FDL program that were made possible
through this partnership with Google
cloud so that is the exoplanet challenge
and the astrobiology challenge so I'll
talk about the exoplanet challenge first
because that was a team that I was
fortunate enough to be on so this is the
exoplanet team
so I was one of the subject matter
experts as a planetary scientist again
I'm at UC Berkeley Hughes born was the
other planetary scientist he's in
Marseilles and then the two deep
learning experts were Jana Jana who just
graduated from the University of
Cambridge with a PhD at me Kelly's
estelí who was a recovery and
astrophysicist and is now at the
University of Adelaide with their
computer vision group we had some great
mentors both on the science and machine
learning side and of course our compute
resources were provided by Google cloud
okay so the challenge that we had was to
increase the fixie and yield of
exoplanet transit classification with
deep learning so I'm gonna break that
down for you and I'll start with the
exoplanet side so first of all what is
an exoplanet so you know everybody knows
our solar system there's the Sun the Sun
is a star there are eight planets in
orbit Nobu's about Pluto not being upon
anymore all right there are eight foot
there you go so there are eight planets
in orbit and so an exoplanet is just a
planet that's orbiting another star
there are a hundred billion stars in our
galaxy and we can now say that on
average every single one of them
contains at least one exoplanet and
that's pretty amazing that I can stand
up here and say this today so the first
exoplanet was discovered in 1995 so
exoplanet science is actually an
incredibly new field in astrophysics and
we now know that we we've detected
thousands of them and we can start
studying them as a population we can
start doing things like estimating you
know the frequency of earth-like planets
around sun-like stars and one of the
reasons why we can do that is because of
the wonderful success of a particular
method for detecting exoplanets and
that's called the transit method that's
what's being shown on the left here so
the transit method works by just taking
advantage of the fact that if you see an
excellent system at a particular
orientation when the planet goes in
front of its host star you see a drop in
brightness of that host star and that
should be a periodic thing every time
the planet goes around you should see a
drop in brightness so we don't actually
resolve what's being shown on the far
left there we don't actually see the
star in the planet what we do is what's
on the in the middle there we measure
the brightness of the star and we just
wait for that drop in brightness and we
wait for a repeating drop in brightness
so one of the reasons why the transit
method is so successful is because of a
mission called the Kepler spacecraft how
many people here have heard of the
Kepler spacecraft that's fantastic
so Kepler was in space for about ten
years but actually its primary mission
which gave us all the data we worked
with in this project was only going on
for about four years
and so they were during this time Kepler
stared at one position in the sky for
four years and looked at about half a
million stars and measured the
brightness of those stars every 30
minutes and was just waiting for these
drops in brightness and because of
through this method Kepler's they were
able to discover over 2,500 exoplanets
so this is pretty amazing this
completely revolutionized the field of
exoplanet science and brought us to
where we are today the Kepler data isn't
pretty so everything I showed you as
wonderful plots it looks great
that's not like what we deal with on a
day-to-day basis so the top plot here is
what we call a light curve so this is a
particular star that Kepler looked at
and the brightness that was measured
every 30 minutes for about 750 days and
you see all this stuff you see this
ramping up you see these drops in
brightness so some of that is spacecraft
systematics some of its instrument noise
some of its actual stellar variability
and only these little bitty drops that
are highlighted by the red triangles are
the exoplanet transit so this is one
exoplanet you see three transits in this
particular time period and so we do a
bunch of stuff to flatten these light
curves so on the bottom panel as you see
a flattened light curve so it's been
cleaned of all these systematics stellar
variability and all you see are their
transits but this is actually pretty
nice data it gets a lot worse than this
and particularly when you have more than
one planet so this is a now-famous
planetary system called the Trappist
system and you see when you have
multiple planets going around you start
getting overlapping transits it's very
hard to sort of tease all this out so
it's hard to work with this data and
find these exoplanets another reason why
it's hard to find these exoplanets is
because there's a variety of false
positive signals that mimic exoplanet
transits and we need to find these and
let them out so one of the main sources
of false positives are EXO our sorry
eclipsing binaries so here you don't
have a planet orbiting a star you
actually
two stars orbiting each other one is
usually smaller than the other and so
you can get things that look a lot like
an exoplanet transit a particular nasty
case are these background eclipsing
binaries so your target star is actually
a single star but there's an eclipsing
binary in the background that you can't
resolve and that can actually look a lot
like an exoplanet transit and then there
are transyl lineman's of stellar
variability instrument noise you know
like the example that I showed before
there are three transits and you can
imagine that in some cases you get
chance alignment of three things that
look like they're on a periodic cadence
and so you get these false positives
that way and that becomes a problem when
you dig into the lowest signal-to-noise
transits which unfortunately usually
correspond to the most interesting cases
of things like earth-like planets in the
habitable and like stars which was the
whole point of Kepler you have to vet
for all these false positives so the way
we do this the Kepler team developed
this very sophisticated pipeline and
I'll go through this very quickly this
is sort of how we traditionally find
exoplanet transits so we start off with
what are called target pixel files these
are little postage stamp images of stars
this is what's actually downloaded from
the spacecraft then we use what we call
aperture photometry so you put on an
aperture you sum all the light within
that aperture and that's how bright the
star is you do that as a function of
time and you get those light curves that
I showed you before that have all this
systematics in it you flatten those then
you do an exoplanet transit search so
you start looking for these transits and
you record everything above a certain
signal to noise threshold you pass that
through a data validation stage so this
is just you start fitting transit models
you start calculating statistics that
can help you identify false positives
and this is an iterative process so you
find one transit you block out the light
curve you send it back into the traffic
transit planet search because as we know
from our solar system stars can host
many planets then when you're done you
feed all of this to a set of humans
humans sit down these are people's jobs
which is kind of cool their job is to
just find exoplanets so they sit around
and they look at you know hundreds of
thousands of these transit events and
they figure out which ones are real
exoplanets and which are not and this is
a very time-consuming process you're
sifting through a lot of data
took years in the case of Kepler but at
the end of the day we get these
wonderful exoplanet catalogs and we can
start answering questions like how
common is our earth
see but this last part this last very
time-consuming part is where deep
learning can help and where it already
is helping and today I'm going to tell
you about how we did that so now I'll
move on to the deep learning side of
what we did and in particular how Google
Klout helped us do this so I'm gonna
give you a 30-second introduction to
deep learning for people aren't too
familiar about it so deep learning is a
subset of machine learning it's called
deep learning because it uses a series
of computational layers to basically
take inputs translate them into more
useful outputs by learning increasingly
complex features in the data neural
networks are a type of deep learning
they're called neural networks because
their architecture sort of is loosely
analogous to the neurons in our brain
and then convolutional neural nets are
type of neural network that takes
advantage of spatial features in the
data and they're particularly good at
classification problems which is
essentially what we're doing or xane is
this a planet or is this not upon it so
the reason why we want to use deep
learning for exoplanet transit science
there's a bunch of them so one it's
quick you train a model and then you can
classify hundreds of thousands of
candidate a truck planet transits within
seconds instead of years it's systematic
so this human reading that I talked to
you about and you know it's full of
biases that you can't tease out so I
didn't have coffee this morning I saw an
eclipsing binary the last time I tried
to vet a candidate I've seen planets the
last ten times I've looked at planets
like all of this stuff biases your
decision-making process and it's really
hard to tease out those biases and
correct for them and so having a
systematic way of doing this is really
important and it's important for
calculating all these exoplanet
statistics that were interested in as
we'll see from this presentation there's
also easy to upgrade these models so you
want to improve your model it's easy to
retrain and apply to new data and it's
quantifiable so you're not just saying
this is an exoplanet this is not an
exoplanet you're saying this is an
exoplanet with 0.8 plus or minus 0.1
probability and again you can fold that
into these exoplanet statistics and make
them a lot more robust so the first
people to actually apply deep learning
to exoplanet transit classification
which Illumina vandenberg 2018 so
crucial who works at Google brain Andrew
Vandenberg is a postdoc in astrophysics
like myself
and they made a model called Astro net
it's available on github if you want to
download it and play with the model the
model
architecture shown on the right but
basically it's a deep convolutional
neural network it was written in
tensorflow
and the inputs are these global and
local views of the phase folded
candidate transit so what I mean by
phase folded is that I showed you these
light curves before that span you know
four years but there's a signal in there
that the periodic so you can fold the
light curve on that period and you get
these nice XO clinic transits that are
shown in the bottom here so they input
these global and local views the global
view is in fort important because it
shows you the whole transit so in the
case of these eclipsing binaries that I
told you about when there are two stars
eclipsing each other you actually get a
primary in a secondary clip so you get
an eclipse when the star when the
smaller star goes in front of the bigger
star and also when it goes behind and
that's because you have you're dealing
with two very bright objects you don't
see that with a planet because the
planet is small and it doesn't have its
own brightness to it so that's important
for identifying things like eclipsing
binaries the local view zooms in on the
transit and maps out its shape in more
detail and this is important because
true planet transits actually have a
pretty unique shape that kind of a
box-like shape that's actually one of
the ways that we can detect them that's
just because the planet is so small
compared to the host star so both of
these are important they're fed in as
separate disjoint 1 1 dimensional
convolutional columns into the model the
outputs of the convolutional columns are
flattened and concatenated then fed
through a series of fully connected
layers and then a sigmoid layer and the
output is this number between 0 and 1
which loosely represents the likeliness
of that particular transit being
associated with a with a true exoplanet
so astronaut did something really cool
discover two new super Earths
in two different systems super earths
are really cool because we don't have
them in our solar system so if you
imagine our solar system which is shown
on the bottom here we have the rocky
planets in the in the inner solar system
and then we have the big gassy ice
giants on the outer solar system and
nothing in between so super ores are
cool because we don't have them in our
own solar system they're also really
cool because it turns out what we know
from Kepler now is that they're by far
the most common type of planet in the
galaxy so they're important and we need
to learn about them
so the Kepler 90 system always also a
sun-like stars was a super-earth around
a sun-like star and it brought that
system it brought it up to eight planets
in the system so it's actually the
system in our galaxy with the most known
exoplanets and it brings it up to a tie
with our own solar system so what we did
over the summer through FDL was to
upgrade Astro net with what we call
added scientific domain knowledge so
it's just information that US scientists
had that could improve the model
performance and it ended up improving it
for particularly the low signal to noise
transits that correspond to earth sized
planets and we called our model EXO net
and it's also available on gate lab if
you want to check the model out the
updated architectures on the right but
what I wanted to do before I get into
the science side of it was just
highlight the role of Google cloud so
Google cloud was really sort of the glue
that held the whole project together so
through it we could make our code in
Python through a collaborative
environment of the Jupiter notebooks we
called on pi torch and scikit-learn to
build and test and train our models and
the whole thing was incredibly seamless
and you know as someone I walked into
the FTL program with no machine learning
experience very little collaborative
coding experience and Google Cloud made
the whole thing incredibly easy to learn
and to pick up each of our team members
had custom is instances we had our own
virtual machines so we could sort of
customize these machines to whatever we
happen to be doing at that moment
whether it was building the model or
training at or testing it we had access
to you know amazing GPU resources and we
used a persistent solid-state drive for
reading our data quickly for training
and so again I just want to you know
highlight as an academic this was
absolutely amazing
let me give you some insight into how it
works in academia so we typically apply
for a grant to NASA or the National
Science Foundation and sometimes those
grants let us buy hardware and so we say
we want to buy this hardware it's
usually not v1 hundreds because then we
would not get the grant approved but you
get some money for hardware if you're
lucky enough and then you go off and you
buy that hardware and then you use that
hardware from the order of five to ten
years sometimes longer and then you get
another grant in the hole
starts over again so it's very slow and
so our resources are not just limited
but they're out of date so to have the
resources that are provided by Google
cloud was was pretty amazing okay so
what did we add to our model to increase
the model performance so one of the
things we added first was a centroid
time series so I showed the light curves
before which is just how bright the star
is as a function of time the other thing
you get from this data so I mentioned
before what we actually get from the
spacecraft are these postage stamp
images so you can lay down an aperture
and measure the brightness within that
aperture but you can also measure the
pixel position of the center of light
within that aperture and that's called
the centroid and you get that as a
function of time so in this case let's
say you have a background eclipsing
binary when that Eclipse happens on that
background source the centroid will
actually shift it'll shift away from
that binary and you can use that
information to identify false positives
so this is what I mean so again these
global and local views of the of the
face folded transit on the top is a real
exponent so you see the transit but you
don't see a shift in the centroid which
is shown in red on the bottom is a
background eclipsing binary and you can
see in the transit you get the shift in
the centroid so you can take advantage
of that information and so the way we
did that was to create secondary
channels in the convolutional columns
and to feed in the centroid time series
along with a light curve the other thing
we did was add stellar properties so one
thing I didn't mention is that with this
transit method the planet properties you
get out actually heavily depend on the
properties of the host star so one of
the things we did was tell the model the
properties of that particular host star
and there's a variety of reasons why
this might help but I'm showing one of
them here so here you have a giant star
being orbited by a main-sequence star
and I'll explain what that means so if
you have a binary system and by the way
half the stars in our galaxy are binary
system so our Sun is single but actually
50% of the stars in the galaxy are
binary so this is an important effect
when you have a binary system they don't
evolve at the same rate they don't age
at the same rate usually one age is
quicker than the other and when that
happens the star blows up and becomes a
giant star we call it a giant star
because we have no imagination but it
gets really puffy our Sun is gonna do
that and when it does that it'll
actually engulf the earth so that's how
big these things
but you can see the size difference it's
actually really similar to a star and a
planet so you can get excellent transits
or things that look like EXO planet
transits when really it's a it's just an
old star with a with a middle-aged star
orbiting it
so we fed in the stellar parameters we
couldn't get any to them to the outputs
of the convolutional columns before the
fully connected layers and that's how we
took advantage of that information so we
were able to increase the model
performance over the baseline Azure net
by a few percent astronaut was already
performing really well so that increase
of just a few percent actually
corresponding to about 50 percent
decreases in model error and there's a
precision recall curve shown on the
right that shows you that the centroids
actually provided the best boost to the
model performance but the stellar
properties also helped what was
interesting though is not just the
overall model performance but it turns
out that we were getting much better
recall almost 20% higher gains in in
recall for exoplanets that corresponded
to that had the lowest transit signal to
noise ratio and these correspond to
earth sized planets so what it's telling
us is that our model EXO net might be
able to find earth-size planets still
lurking in the Kepler data and that's
what we're working on right now okay so
at the end of the day we were able to
show that scientific domain knowledge
improves exoplanet transit
classification with deep learning and
all the scientists let out a big sigh
that their jobs are not being taken by
the machines just yet probably soon them
okay so that was the exoplanet challenge
and now I'll spend some time talking
about the astrobiology challenge my
colleague Molly Alberto is supposed to
be here but unfortunately she couldn't
make it so I'm gonna do the best I can
to share with you their work so this is
the astrobiology team from last year so
Molly Oberon and Michael Himes with the
planetary scientists and Frank Zola's
esky and Simone Azores on were the
planetary scientists or sorry with the
computer scientists they also had
wonderful mentors on the science and
machine learning side and of course
Google Cloud was the was the partner was
the industry partner okay
are we alone that's a question that's
been asked for hundreds if not thousands
of years and what's really exciting is
that we're actually at a time when we
might be able to answer this
in the near future we might be able to
detect signatures of life on another
planet so the first step is finding
those other planets and as I just showed
you we're getting pretty good at that
but the next step after that is to
figure out which one of those planets is
most suitable for life and therefore
where we should look for life where is
the most likely place that we can detect
life and that's that's the hard part
that's still pretty hard so the
challenge for the archeology team was to
use machine learning to try and identify
possible extraterrestrial life on other
worlds sounds pretty easy right but they
did have a starting point so what
scientists think they want to do is to
look at the atmospheres of exoplanets
and in particular to look for molecules
or groups of molecules in those
atmospheres that are indicative of
biological activity on the surface of
those planets and so those are
collectively called bio signatures and
we can actually do this we can detect
molecules in the atmospheres of
exoplanets but only for these hot
Jupiters so very massive planets very
close to their star and the way we do
this is we get a spectrum so we use
telescopes in space to get a spectrum of
the atmosphere and that spectrum has
fingerprints of these molecules and we
use something called atmospheric
retrieval to infer the actual
composition of that atmosphere from that
spectrum the problem is at atmospheric
retrieval the traditional way of doing
it is incredibly in it's incredibly
time-consuming so it takes days if not
weeks on supercomputers to actually back
out atmospheric composition from a
spectrum so this is where machine
learning a different approach can can
speed this up so the astrobiology team
created a code called Inara it stands
for the intelligent exoplanet
atmospheric retrieval so Inara is really
cool it's an all-in-one flexible
open-source tool so it starts by
generating planetary spectra using
NASA's planetary spectrum generator or
PSG so the reason why the Astro biology
had to generate its data is what I just
mentioned we can only measure exoplanet
atmospheres for these hot Jupiters for
earth-like planets it's much more
difficult we're not quite there yet but
there are plans for spacecraft in the
future to be able to do this and so this
is very important precursor work and so
with the
monetary spectrum generator does is
it'll produce Athan synthetic spectrum
based on certain spacecraft
configurations and a given planetary
atmosphere so they created these spectra
they can be saved locally or to a Google
Cloud bucket and then there's other in
our instances that can pull that data
out and then on the fly train and
validate and test a machine learning
model and to predict these planetary
atmospheres and this is available as a
Python package or a docker container and
the average astrobiology team created
three million of these simulated rocky
exoplanet spectra and these are
different combinations of about 28
planetary and stellar properties and it
output twelve atmospheric models
including these bio signatures so this
is like by far the largest library of
exoplanet spectra there is available and
it's all publicly available so this is
more of a visual visual way of what I
just said so this is the Inara Google
cloud platform landscape so there there
was the data generation size and again
three million unique spectra and they
used two thousand cloud virtual machines
to do this so the way it was laid out is
that there were these virtual machine
nodes that had the nasa psg tool on them
and then sixteen on our docker instances
were connected to each of those nodes
careering the PSG to make spectra and
then those instances were saving the
spectra to a Google Cloud bucket and
then they were separate in our machine
learning training instances that were
connected to that Google Cloud bucket
actively reading those out and training
the models on the fly and the
astrobiology team did a grid search of
70 model architectures primarily written
in PI courts but they also explored
different frameworks using Karason
tensorflow and what's also cool about
this is that if you had a project that
was sort of similar to this you can take
this framework and just input your own
spectrum generator or what generator of
whatever and then input your own machine
learning model and so this whole
framework is set up and you can actually
just play and play whatever you need for
your for your science needs so this is a
model architecture they decided on in
the end it's actually quite similar to
the exoplanet one it's a one dimensional
convolute a series of one dimensional
convolutional layers with max pooling
which were then fed through some fully
connected layers at the end so this is a
result from just a random planet from
from their sample only four five
molecules so it's a bit hard to see but
there are some red stars that are the
true value of that planetary atmosphere
and then the sort of colorful blobs are
the predictions from the model and
you're getting a distribution because
this was actually a Bayesian deep
learning model that took advantage of
concrete dropout to create these
posterior distributions so you can say
you can see it does pretty well for
these molecules but it actually predicts
12 molecules this is much more than than
other planetary retrieval methods and of
course the big benefit is that you know
this is created in seconds whereas
previously atmospheric retrieval
requires days to do the same thing
alright so in the end the astrobiology
team generated a three million rocky
exoplanet spectra and developed its
first machine Mladic machine learning
atmospheric retrieval model for rocky
terrestrial exoplanets like the earth so
this was pretty pretty amazing and it's
all publicly available if you wanted to
play around with it okay so um that's
all I had for you now um I I've had a
great time sharing with you I hope you
had a great time learning about some of
the cool science that can be done for
the Google cloud platform and I just
want to finish by saying like this was
an amazing experience for me to go
through this program again I had zero
machine learning experience going into
this and the tools that are available
through the Google cloud platform made
it not just easy to learn but also
enjoyable and fun to learn so I'm very
excited to see all the future science
that can come out of collaborations with
the Google cloud platform thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]